okay for those joining the livestream
this is our hundredth internal product
design review meeting that we have live
streamed this one happens to be about
geometry and adding geometric proving
capabilities to of language so let's
start off understanding what we're
talking about here so this is a okay so
you okay so you here you have a pure
angle construct oh no now you've still
got this counterclockwise angle
clockwise angle stuff so this is saying
there is a triangle ABC notice notice
the label is previous Engel discussion
oh so this is the previous version okay
fine which has lots of different kinds
of angles so this is just saying there
is a triangle there is a polygon
and then this is referring to that
polygon
Wow okay I didn't know we could do this
with it with a kind of a dummy variable
here p1 that's not declared because the
things that are declared there are all
points right you can declare points you
can also declare variables corresponding
to scalar quantities but if you want to
have just a placeholder you can you can
you not declare it anywhere you can just
sue p1 equals equals whatever you want
but how do you declare scalars so the
the first argument is currently just a
list of points you can also make it a
list of two lists where the first list
is the list of points in the second list
is the list list of scalar variables so
if you wanted to say have an angle equal
90 degrees plus X you would do the the
two list form of the first argument and
have X in the in the second list so so
we believe that geometry then is sort of
points and scalars that those are the
two kinds of things that appear what
about operators for example why not have
a I mean if we were doing general
equational logic for example in here we
would also have arbitrary binary
operators and stuff like that but I
don't think we need this before the
elementary objects it's it's in some
sense like the second argument to solve
like the variable like things well but
except there's a third argument there
which is more like the what is that like
I'm because because usually when you
think about a formal system right there
are things like there are variables
there are operators there are you know
there's collection of three or four
different kinds of things in the
language for a formal system and here
some what I mean in other words these
things here stand for points but this
thing here is being effectively set up
to stand for a polygon yes but it's
folio has formed semantics of equal no I
understand that but I mean you're saying
that the fundamental sort of variable
like things in geometry are points
and things like circles adi which are
scalar quantities yeah so I I this is
using like confusing
well this technique the separation
between somehow the sphere of quantities
are more fundamentally and also saying
you know using equal to make a
declaration as opposed to stating an
equality but there's no no there's no
difference this this is just stating the
Equality that P 1 whatever it might be
is equivalent to know it's stating that
T 1 is that polygon let me finish
Michael there because then you're
referencing it inside so you're saying T
1 is that yeah but that's the same way
that you're referencing a inside or G
inside here it's no more saying it is
it's it's like saying it is equal to but
it is not this doesn't evaluate it I I I
understand that it doesn't evaluate but
but logically this is baffling and wrong
I mean do you want
I either P 1 is that polygon wait a
second what would happen if it said P 1
equals equals midpoint of blah blah blah
I think you'd be happy with that only if
P 1 were declared as a point right I
mean the part that's somewhat strange
about this is that P 1 is an arbitrary
symbolic structure and for some reason I
mean the point is that if P 1 wasn't
equal equal to this then putting up C 1
there the whole thing becomes untethered
and meaningless right that's kind of you
if you had P 1 so for one thing it's
logically wrong right yes it should be
set you're saying that P 1 is that
polygon you might kind of you know
it's not like in anything you make solve
a equally a equal B plus C you just
stated but I said it but you don't say
you don't say but then you don't talk
about the you know the properties of a
you say ank-ooo equals three and then I
either say ski is a prime or say a it's
apartment boots are equivalent
statements let's keep going for a minute
that I think we need to come back to
this question about declaration of the
the kind of the primitive objects here
which are sort of implicitly being
assumed to be points I think it's really
weird that this thing is hanging out
like that but let's let's keep going
because we find it very natural okay
well let's let's keep going here two
fundamental ways of thinking about
angles okay so the main topic we're
going to be discussing today is defining
angles and one of our goals is to reduce
the absurd number of different kinds of
angles that we're talking about here so
do we have a are we bottom line okay so
we have a proposal down here let's take
a look at that before we okay fine I
think this is going to be I'm optimistic
about this but let's take a look at what
we said previously about thinking about
angles angle as shape angle as rotation
okay
two different yeah obviously that's
right there are two different angles I
mean but in general you could say the
acute angle or the or the reflex angle
associated with this or you could say
the clockwise angle or the counter
clockwise I go that's through different
ways well but no if you say clockwise or
counterclockwise you need to say which
one you're starting from sure right so
so angle so angle says turns our ordered
pairs was angles as sort of shapes are
our unordered fits right okay so the
measure of
is the smaller of these that's kind of
weird so this is a discontinuous thing
as you go through as you move this
around as you go through 188
discontinuously jumps the value
corresponding to this angle thing that
true correct
okay and while in many circumstances
right if you go around it will be
continuous no no but no what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that by convention to
measure is this the the measure of the
angle is two smaller of these that's
only true in certain circumstances right
if you like because this is why you have
interior polygons or an exterior since
they're it's not necessarily the smaller
but when you're talking about angles as
shapes it measures the smaller one is
what just happened here why did this
fail if I say geometric seen here of
this that's gonna do nothing okay so if
I said so let's try this one again is
this just gonna crash but it's enough to
to use nothing you find you have to run
the run code on the package again oops
that's all I wanted um
all right let me don't want to
everything is already evaluated so you
can just not evaluate everything all
right um could whoever's typing put
themselves on mute okay what's this
doing I just crashed first yeah so you
think it's going to work for 90 degrees
whoever's making noise please put
themselves on mute
this is eleven point three
I don't know it's the 12 prototype build
I hope that could be the explanation
all right let me let me start using 11:3
here um all right let me run this code
11 3 let's check
this works so this taking its time up
there we go that worked okay so now here
let's try changing that to sixty degrees
how beautiful I'm a little confused oh I
see I see I see I get it so for example
if I were to add to this angle
[Music]
X
zy equals equals that angle equals six
degrees Oh wonderful very nice one
equilateral triangle um cool okay but
now this angle function right now that's
not evaluating any way whereas for
example the function vector angle does
evaluate right
correct angle angle does not evaluate
okay so
it's a little weird that as a measure
one might expect it to evaluate so we
probably need a name that does not
indicate that it is like the evaluating
we also need to distinguish it in some
way from Vicki I think the opposite I
think we just will implement it to
evaluate in the future
no but that's not good no yeah what does
it even mean I mean so so no it just to
make sure we you cannot try it line a B
equals three centimeter that makes no
sense you would have to say arc length
of line do we want to be able to say
angle equal 60 degree or do we want any
measure of angles to say 60 degree is
the first question
let's keep going
I don't know the answer to that okay
okay so okay fine
so that's the question I don't really
understand I mean it's something okay
you're gonna have a better proposal
illness okay fine
angle addition postulate
so what is the point here
the point is we need oriented angles if
we're talking about
summing up they were dealing with
consecutive angles
sure
okay okay polygon angles
okay so that is given a polygon
I'm actually totally confused by this I
mean here
this is just for drawing the polygon
that you included here right correct it
actually it doesn't need to be in there
if you delete that it'll it'll it'll be
the same thing right so this is saying
there is a polygon
and okay so the issue is really which
angle at this point I mean to define
this point at a right you actually don't
need all you need is e a and B to define
that angle if you want it to be an
interior polygon is done to know that
it's interior you have to know that all
the polygon points correct
because it you need the topology of the
whole thing as well as okay okay so
which of the kit okay exterior polygon
angle I get it
okay what's this now
so this this was though the non simple
polygon would be for if we were
implementing this outside of geometric
scene we only have simple polygons
inside so we don't really need to deal
with it but if region people in the
kernel group want to implement it
implement rubber region people there is
a geometry team geometries I want to
implement what angle camera clockwise
angled interior polygon angle etc yes
but you're saying that this definition
that that happens for non simple
polygons is a generalization of your
definition or is it incompatible with
your definition
it's compatible ok guys let's go on
we'll have some more complicated cases
and part unoriented angle I don't
understand this
okay so we could do I was moving around
please put themselves on mute
you
okay I mean certainly the concept of
defining what you mean by angle
like this seems sensible I think it's
sensible to me
I mean what is the unoriented angle
again
is that always the the the acute angle
always a cuter obtuse but not reflux so
right between 0 and 180 okay I don't
think necessarily unoriented is the
right name for that but I understand the
concept um okay now
arguably
[Music]
the clockwise versus counterclockwise is
I mean how could it not be the angle
from A to C
and could it be right it's always from A
to C which direction do you take do you
go clockwise from A to C or do you go
counterclockwise from A to C okay I get
it
okay for the proposal with you if you
didn't put in that second argument you'd
assume it was it was that an oriented
you know I didn't I think it is a good
but this is really weird that there's a
polygon
I I think that's that's potentially
backwards or at least confusing because
if we're defining it as turn right it
should be the angle from the
continuation of I don't remember what
what what the points we had were they
ABC right it should be the rotation from
ABC from the continuation that they need
to be seen
okay what happens if we do something
like angle line a B comma line BC or so
or a line let's say well I don't think
you know angle C to keep line there is
to take lines I mean it's if it's a
fundamental object then it's not
something that calculates things out of
those arbitrary arguments but wait a
minute but those lines which coincide at
the point B why is that not a perfectly
I mean you know to me that's the analog
of polygon angle no it's the analog of
vector angle call it that's the same
thing as vector angle that is vector
angle and vector angle we should
generalize to K flats you know I find
spaces but that was the point that
essential to define an angle essentially
you need a point on your way right you
know if you decide to find it from three
points and PC define those point on way
right the same is you have a cone right
you have the up x point and a you define
it and this in four solid angle
so maybe the differential shouldn't be
based on point but on the actual
geometric object but but you don't know
if you take the outside or the inside
hold on watch out the safest so Charles
are saying there is an anchor point
which in this case is the point X in
this case is the point B right there's
an anchor point for the at which the
angle is being evaluated so to speak and
then there is the the thing that
determines kind of where the arms go
relative to that point that what you
were saying Charles yes but then if you
think on the sphere is the tent of being
the anchor point and a couple of points
you could still basically take the two
complimentary parts that span it
I agree but let's look at the solid
angle case for a match because the solid
angle there's a center so you know every
I mean essentially what we're saying is
every angle has a a has a point that it
is defined at right and then it has
there has some kind of extent that a
fair statement so for a solid angle of
extent well I think it's kind of mean
like a cone you know a generalized not
just ice cream count but any yes yes yes
okay let's look at the solid I know case
for a second okay and by the way we
might get away with calling this plane
angle
maybe not sure or point angle but let's
let's keep going for a second okay
so okay could you walk me through the
solid angle case so there's a there's a
point at which it's defined some point P
and then how do you specify the cone of
solid angle you would have you would
have some kind of boundary curve one say
as feel and one point inside or it might
just be a Delta Theta so to speak around
that point on the sphere if it's a I
think that's that's one one way Michael
that's one way to generate that cone my
cone I don't mean a regular cone
Jenna mean something me too okay good
but it's not is that a valid mean
account cone you have to define it I
mean you need a pointed cone to begin
with right
okay when you say such and such a number
of sister radians on the sky let's say
you mean that the fraction well first of
all now you're talking about not solid
angle but solid angle measure yes
and second of all what you need is that
fraction of the total sphere which is
you know locked or you know taken up by
whatever it is you're measuring times 4
pi like that's the measuring stir agents
yeah yeah right but okay so let me walk
through again what you mean by okay so I
wasn't listening carefully enough when
you talk about angle measure versus
angles for the planar case like the
anger is the geometric object the 30
degree is the measure like a line and
the length of a line we go in at the
area what what do you mean what is the
angle is it a point now the anger is
kind of does not just stop definition
following Euclid most closely the angle
would be two housemaids at the point
yeah so that that would be that would be
like a cone yeah okay so without the
interiour yeah yeah I got a surface of a
cone basically right it's kind of like
the intersection of that cone with the
ending in this planar case right it's
intersection of that cone with a unit
circle you know we put the center it's
it's something it's a little bit like
arrow arrow is a graphics primitive but
but what is it
the develop is not really defined right
and let me point out that this is the
angle that you're talking about there's
only one of the two planar angles we can
talk about this is the angle as shaped
as opposed to the angle s turn which is
you have an ordered pair of rays and now
you're talking about right so the first
one is pointing and you know you're
talking about how one is rotated from
the other the second is from the first
yes I understand
so okay so you're saying you're
identifying there's what you're calling
shape the geometry well angle as shape
you're saying versus angle as turning
yes and we've won both like we want
angular shape for anyone to indicate
angle inside a polygon and denote it and
we want anger as a turning by for
instance having a line and carrying out
the rotation transform on this line so
let's write down those cases okay let's
write down what we mean by that so angle
S shape
give me an example of that so you say
integrate what no I mean angle as shape
is like this I mean you integrate this
what do you mean it's like disk it's a
it's like the disk like the incomplete
disk well no I just think the disk is an
arbitrary geometric you know primitive
in two dimension
yeah but I mean it does in fact support
things like this and we should figure
out how we're compatible with things
like this there does actually not be
compatible because two seems hard-coded
you know horizontal right pointing are
you right okay this is a mental note
Angus well no I mean it's yes but it
right it's thinking out a sector right
so if you want a big one like you know
you need right 332 light 290 or
something right okay but angle but but
Michael is saying that in our untethered
geometry so to speak we don't want to
have this relative thirty degrees from
the coordinate axis or anything like
that but but a shape don't don't you
mean the circle right it in the disk I
mean I mean no no I mean I think after
much discussion I think we all agree
that it's the Rays it's it's the point
and the - right so you really mean the
cone then or the boundary of the count I
really think the nearest equivalent is L
on its own makes no sense
you need something to attach the arrow
to yet this is a graphics primitives and
similar I feel like as angle you need
air well it's a graphics primitive no
yes there it is error
alvaro odd row oh right so arrow has to
have two points right but arrow is just
lying with a funny in yes right there
can be a Multi multi point range
primitive in the sense that there are no
qualitative features that you cannot
avoid what happened I don't think you
can use pointer has to receive the
vectors so you need to give a specific
ordinate
not point I think this should be allowed
the good should turn pink
oh we could we allow it Charles is that
for you or is that for Brett we can't do
butch we come to the typesetting okay
all right anyway that's a minor point
okay so I'm still pretty confused here
so what you are proposing let's try to
walk through what's being proposed here
okay so in the end you are proposing
that um we have something I mean so
we've already got existing functions
right we've already got vector angle
which evaluates based on - you know this
is the angle between so no it's the
vector angle Mitchell yeah factor angle
is really the measure angle between
those vectors those vectors being
arbitrary vectors and in env right so
you have a but I mean right basically by
the law of cosines right because we're
we have a Mexican in the round so he
from doctors yep okay so now you are
proposing that there's some kind of you
know plain planar angle or something and
there's some polygon angle polygon angle
takes you came a polygon together with
one of the points to the polygon now all
these functions supposed to evaluate if
this polygon was a concrete polygon with
numerical values no this evaluate no
anymore than line sit evaluate they
represent the angle measure why
shouldn't they evaluate well I don't
think they represent the angle measure
you represent the angle where AB we're
using it to represent the angle measure
we say polygon angle equals 30 degree
I think I personally think this should
work it's a nice convenient but it's
it's a it's a short form for a more
elaborate version
okay well let's understand well maybe we
should think of it the other way around
it would you know what should be easiest
e is the angle measure and if you want
that other abstract object object maybe
it should be called something else I can
go object or something yeah okay so but
but let's understand I mean the the yes
right but so that what it's one way you
can get the metal from the object but
you can't get object from the metal yeah
but okay so we need we we can I
introduce angles for these piecewise
linear objects in in the in the in the
other bigger geometry world and they
need to evaluate yes but so okay what
what evaluating things do we need so we
have this thing that takes vectors V 1 V
2 right and now it would also be in that
one will and I'll sort assert shortly
yet one should generalize to any linear
spaces or affine spaces okay fine
equally well just but so then there's
the notion of what one might call a
point angle or angle between points
subtended angle so a reasonable word I
mean subtended I think it's typically in
literature only used for solid angles
but it's technically collector as well
but what I mean by that is those are
three points right it's the angle define
it and that's why you'd have to give the
the whole sort of story of is it the
clockwise angle etc etc etc right but
it's the angle defined by those three
points as opposed to events defined by
two vectors right I mean we could call
them we could I mean I think people
might use the term proper angle or the
thing that it's neither clockwise nor
countertop that's okay fine so that but
that's that's part of that naming um
okay um but um but I want to know about
this name here because now we've we've
got a third name here well okay in 3d
does that mean anything was that
hopelessly not meaningful in 3d if you
only have three points it's very well
maybe angle proper angle makes sense
because you could like three points lie
in a plane and so you certainly can talk
about the proper angle now clockwise and
counter clockwise become problematic
because you don't know what yeah but you
could argue that for 3d you add another
point for fairness I mean you have this
what does it add a normal or a way of
looking at the plane okay which is
similar to what you'd have to do with
the polygons and for polygons we don't
need co-players a counterclockwise from
the ordering of the point we did use
less than normal fair enough
do we need a convention to reduce the
normal we do we need a right hand rule
or something to deduce the normal but we
have such a convention yes we do
yes phase form implements that in fact
convention this is the sites to them
right well of course I mean we only have
normal if if all those points of the
polygon line is in the plane it's been
me not those are the different
assumptions I mean it's a rather weird
that we have to in the symbolic case
repeating the name of the I mean really
what we would do if we were doing this
okay if we were doing this purely you
know numerically so to speak we will
probably give the index and the polygon
here wouldn't we yes
seems a little bit or to me because
typically only within function like
graphics complex measures to be referred
to in disease not how else do we do it I
mean otherwise we have to reproduce the
new you know the random value of the
core and the elements of the polygon
yeah relatively well the other
possibility would be the other obvious
possibility which I'm not necessarily
recommending is that it is always let's
say the first point in the polygon which
is the one that you are referring to
then you need to operate with rotate
right and left all the time and things
yeah I know
which seems annoying yeah I don't like
this because if you want to specify a
bunch of polygon angles then you can't
say P 1 equals polygon and keep
repeating that you have to I mean Kinect
was the motivation to actually have a
polygon angle I mean that is you know we
can angle from the line from curve are
we going to introduces you know
different had an object for each of the
geometric object if you have to courage
intersect you can define an angle from
it
which are based on this tangent okay
explain Charles are you saying that
there's a notional region angle well at
least for me do you know the angle is
like cities that figure that's like
define your shape between you know to
raise or point so you can apply the same
for curve you can apply the same for
line you can apply the same for poly
career explain explain it again on a
curve what are you talking about for the
angle on a curve so if two curve
intersect yes essentially you can you
know if you build if you draw the
tangent between you take the tangent at
the decision point for two for each of
the curve Kengo all right okay okay
generalization of angles right but the
point is that there are theorem well you
go ahead to what the objects intersect
that defines of various angles the point
is that there are various theorems that
if you want to generalize them from
convex polygons to non convex polygons
you need to be able to talk about angles
not as you know you need to be able to
talk about defying interior and exterior
angles which will be different from just
you know those three points but you
really need the angle s turn if you
still want those theorems to be true
okay and look that's what I mean I'm not
whether this justifies this whole
concept is a different question but that
is the reason why these the synthetic
geometry folks want the polygon angle
cost is because what because if you want
to have theorems like the sum of the
exterior angles of the polygons is a
multiple of 360 then first of all you
need to know what an exterior angle is
and it's not defined by the three points
it's defined by the whole shape and it's
defined as a turn okay
but let's go back to this two one do
sorry yes there's a conceptually the
reason I agree but negatively it's also
because the name interior angle polygon
occurs a lot in the high school
exercises do we want to have this of all
negative translations fine but I'm
trying to understand let's go we've got
several levels of problem here okay
so first point is the claim is given so
in this definition this will be like
angle between maybe I'm confused here
but but help me out angle between line
and line is that correct is that a
meaningful thing that would be like
vector angle
no because it could be right there are
two sort of proper angles if they're not
oriented yeah okay fine fine yes that
two different angles but but
fundamentally that's the kind of thing
the vector angle is so that's one type
of thing another is angle well we could
say subtended I'm just writing it out in
full by and then I would write out a
list of points a point B Point C correct
well maybe I mean I were I would expect
an angle subtended by to take one point
and then an arbitrary shape and it's the
angle subtended by that whole shape as
seen from the point in the first
argument okay walk me through what that
is the correct definition of the word
subtended okay we're so explain this to
me so this is point B and then how do
you represent the shape here any and any
any valid 2d graphics primitives so it's
a Norwegian thing right and it's right
you use you know what arc what fraction
of the unit circle when projected on you
know around B is cut off and by region
that's the angle subtended by that
region yep okay yeah this makes sense to
me and that generalizes to any dimension
angle yeah fine so okay so this is the
part of the unit sphere circle slash
sphere
that quotes seas region I would say is
blocked by region as seen from me
okay okay which by the way is the taking
a definition that defines the sites of
traffic signs but they must up stand
certain solid angles to be acceptable
that's why they come in different sizes
depending how high they are how far they
are on the left
what's interesting okay okay so and then
there's the measure of that okay so this
this is a very weird notion of angle I
mean it's it's some gosh what would you
really call this I mean subtended is the
right term there but what's the real
term I mean this is hardly when people
say I know spend it's a simple one woody
but the word angle usually means an
angle measure basically well I think
that what it is is when people say angle
they're conflating two different ideas
yeah and they're so this idea the part
of the unit circle that's yeah I mean
that from a given point oh gosh what
will we do with this though I mean like
like this is in a sense this is I mean
in in 1 D 1 to D you know this is
basically a bunch of intervals
yo inflator space yep okay and in in 3d
it's a bunch of regions in Theta Phi
space yep
um what is this in in the Geo world
what's the analogous thing in the Geo
world to this so is this like geo area I
don't think it is quite no no it's given
a point
it's the bearings in which direction do
you still see Italy or something from a
given point a fairly bizarre concept I
mean it's the it's the collection of
rays that take you which paths lead to
Rome so to speak
no not Rome because it's doing extended
region is that correct which paths link
to yes it's the fraction of the race
it's the fraction of the geodesics from
you that lead to well by fraction we
don't you mean the fraction we me it's
the bundle of geodesics it's the
directions of the geodesics the bearings
of the geodesics right
this set of yes the set of bearings of
geodesics okay okay let's go back here
all right so that is the notion boy that
that's a notion which wasn't even
discussed over here isn't that right
because we to be he don't need us I get
in normal high school exercise this kind
of angle doesn't mellow okay okay but
this kind of angle defined by three
points is used all the time correct
and what that means is in a way I mean
in a way that's a special case of what
we just talked about right because that
point there B is the point that you have
separated out yeah sure you can't miss
at least one representative of the
region to basically have a real
equivalent why the region is just those
two rays and the directions of em and
you know it's more than two it's kind of
thought 1 which tells us inside or
outside no it's it's the right I think
it's probably in all cases the angle
subtended by so angle ABC would be the
angle subtended by the lying a CD a
scene from be alright my 20 north of
sight well but if we referred to talking
about proper angle and that's the we
always mean that that's correct if you
know now if we want to talk about anti
proper and clockwise and counter
clockwise now we have a whole other
range of thing okay
so let's zoom out again we're trying to
okay so in kind of the high school
geometry case um Euclid Euclid's style
geometry the claim is that in that case
we want this situation right three
points defining an angle
and not much else together with
clockwise and counter-clockwise yeah
fine fine fine fine what would you call
that if you were qualifying the word
angle because we're not really going to
call this angle because - that's too
general a name for this rather specific
thing what would you call us anger -
angle angle sir
great the either plane angle or angle 2d
planar angle
right except these points don't have to
live in 2d so calling an angle TVs bad
but planar angle makes sense yes all
right because these three points will
lie in a plane no matter what okay
so let's imagine that there's planar
angle and then we'll discuss what sub
cases of that there are then what is the
polygon angle case should we just call
it polygon angle as you've as you've
been suggesting is that I mean if
okay so polygon angle just give it a
polygon would it assume the first point
in the polygon no I think you'd have to
list the points okay but but but in the
symbolic case it's fine and dandy to
list a point and the nonsan okay but
actually the next question is does
planar angle evaluate with non symbolic
things in it - what - what could it
avoid it
well put the value a to the measure of
that thing right so I mean if we're
thinking of piece as as measures as has
been suggested basically some people I
mean it either evaluates or you can't
say blah blah blah equals 30 degrees you
can't have it both ways
I think yeah I mean kind of a natural
extension of meaning you can okay well
but but what will be wrong with it for
the purposes of symbolic geometry okay
first question is vector angle it does
evaluate
say vector angle of v1 v2 it's not going
to evaluate
if we give it to lists of the same
length than it would right so they're
like I would like to style an angle and
the wrapping a style around a geometric
shape object or primitive steams and
flipping a style around so DT clear I
find very strange no it's crazy right I
mean maybe you should call it angle
shape just to be very explicit about it
what's the relation between the angular
beam angle
angle would be the measure of the angle
shape so this particular thing of a list
of three I mean so so these points if
they were given explicit coordinates
then it can evaluate or in the alighted
form if it's given you know something
like this it can evaluate
but just like Vectra angle it doesn't
evaluate if it's given symbolic inputs
yeah but it sort of has to mean the same
thing right because if you're gonna
reason about it it has to mean the same
thing because if you substitute concrete
things it should just be true right well
yeah right but that's exactly what what
geometric scene when you do an instance
of a geometric scene it's saying the
point a is the actual values blah blah
blah so I think it was that equal sign
there you know we'll evaluate to true if
I filled in the correct values for the
points a B and C has coordinates this
would compute a value which would turn
out to be 30 degrees not because the
unit weight the other one probably ho
chun-yin region that one is indigwe
that one is in radians degree my degree
is in radians the t-coil do not figure
it out but the degree sign is just a
factor white but they call will not
figure it out you do not even know I
will figure out in this case yes so we
are going to attend a unit no this case
is not a unit
okay degree is not a unit there there is
the case pi over 2 equals equals
something where I can say control equal
90 degrees
the heck does that mean you means the
things you have a scaler okay so I can
comment on this active put some long
page evaluation for the International
Committee because I was asked there's a
discussion if Reagan is an independent
base unit and there's no International
equipment or this Italy and the US would
like it to be a independent base unit
Germany would not like this so today
I'll stay in mate right now
how long has a business in a stalemate
on that topic it has come up repeatedly
over the last 25 years
okay I thought you might say a hundred
years stand on this because they are a
spy that make an institute they follow
the American opinion okay this message
is is leaves a bit to be desired
what do you mean it's invalid you
compare things that you can't compare
well I don't think the word invalid is
rather unfortunate here I can guess it
Kate I can speak with Nick okay okay but
let's come back to this let's see
Andorra sending us something on the live
stream let's just evaluate his piece of
code which I don't necessarily
understand but let's take a look at this
okay and the question is would the angle
also work if B is not repeated
No what do you mean if B is no I mean so
here um I think that must be with with
them I will between also work if if B is
not repeated oh I see this case here I
think that's I mean vector angle has a
meaning that because it is the
displacement vectors right essentially
the Rays if I'm not mistaken yes okay
let's let's loop back to this here
okay so hypothesis we can have a thing
called planar angle it evaluates if
given explicit inputs it remains
unavailable if it is symbolic it
represents the it evaluates to the angle
measure of that planar angle relative to
three points it somewhat
zolly we would have the convention that
will you to merely mention it it behaves
like an angle shape I mean with respect
to geometric scene that's a hack yes I
think you should never behave as an
angle shape should always behave as a
measure okay but then if you want to
annotate your picture should answer you
angle shape I don't really like the term
shape what would be a better term for
this what is this thing called that
little thingy dinghy what is that called
that must have some official name if
it's been around as long as Euclid which
it has it's going to have an official
name I'm the developer angle indicator I
wouldn't call it an angle shape because
it isn't really a shape but so what
would angle indicator then have in it it
would say I mean I think it would be
really it would be really good to be
able to use that as a graphics primitive
now I agree
so then angle indicator takes three
points right and it is by convention oh
you know
is gonna be problematic as a graphics
primitive because the sizing of it is
all it will be a free repeat of mo
our heads and everything too to give
meaning to it
mmm well that's life I mean it's
complicated
well it's complicated I don't think
that's a bad thing necessarily I think
it's a useful and it's gonna take a
little work to figure that because it
needs to scale I get it but I know this
naturally would be the most natural
meaning of a angle indicator would be
the the angle subtended going from or am
i confused going from see the turn angle
from A to C now you would get in this
case the other one well I think you know
from the second argument but then yes so
you know it could be direction there too
right so so what you indicated now is
counterclockwise would you say from am I
saying counterclockwise now if I'm
looking at the picture on the left
doesn't make any difference I could I
could switch that picture around there's
still a well-defined turn angle from A
to C if B is a well-defined smaller
turning goal you said a to C but you
your mouse indicated C to a well fine
that's because this picture look if it's
from A to C oh boy
I see you
you could go either way yeah and you
usually draw a little arrow on it no I
don't think so you see much more
pictures with a devil in a normal tie
younger German I'm wrong that's wrong
about the turn angle thing that's just
wrong um rather it would be by default
at the proper angle right
and the other case would be let's see
that the other case would be the
clockwise angle and the counterclockwise
angle those are the cases is that right
and what about interior next year ear
angles well that's not the fine looks
that makes sense for three points no but
there are angle indicators for interior
angle so this is polygon case yeah this
angle indicator only encompasses the
three points well so most likely what we
would end up wanting to do there is some
kind of polygon arrow something like
that what do you think or a point a
arrow polygon or something what's the
right way see what's nasty here because
then if we could get this to work okay
possible possible idea that the full
version of this or a version of this is
this and that this then generalizes to
the more complicated okay so let's
imagine it was this then that's the
angle indicator then planar angle works
the same way
okay that is that the there's a simple
form which is this one here but that the
more decorated form is point B arrow
subtending points so to speak and that
one could imagine generalizing to point
B arrow region
so I could imagine something which says
subtended but that's not what you mean
in there in the polygon case you
literally pick out the two neighboring
points to a yeah okay so so okay so help
me out understanding the generalization
of that sander on our live stream is
suggesting the interesting term angle
arc that's a pretty good name actually
that's better than shape or indicator oh
yes well I see I see I see that would be
the alternative angle indicator um
interesting the only thing that that
makes reminds me of I still think angle
indicator might be preferable because I
think that there might be things that
aren't necessarily arcs that I get but
it only applies to 2d fine but okay but
now what we're addressing this issue
about the polygon case and
okay so but fundamentally we've got two
things we're dealing with here
okay so do we agree the planar angle
fundamentally is a thing that remains
symbolic if there is see what I'm saying
that the merely given symbols it remains
unavailable it's given numeric vectors
but now notice that within your
geometric scene setup you probably need
to be able to handle vector angle as
well right within in in the geometric
scene case right there's no reason why
let's see back up here there's no reason
why you can't have vector angle let's
say with the UM oh gosh this is gonna be
a mess isn't it because if you go a B I
know I know it's a total mess I because
vector angle that's it's ambiguous
whether those correspond to points
defining lines well yeah fair enough and
those are just coordinates and and if
you wanted to do the other thing you'd
have to do something like this does that
make any sense or do we should be not
even go there well right I mean unless
were declaring this
a guest is probably made some I'm not
sure because normal rate vectors
actually have a direction which slimes
do not although this may not matter for
the purposes of grains alright okay but
let's go back and to planar angle and so
on okay so one of the remaining issues
is
this will that's irrelevant of course
but this idea of picking out a point in
a polygon which angle do you mean first
of all it's the interior or exterior
yeah you'd still need a second argument
strong enough but fine fine we could
have that I mean it would default to
interior probably Bergeron is the notion
of a polygon angle different from a
generic planar angle not really yeah the
polygon has to lie in a plane in order
for this to make sense yeah okay you're
it well you're saying this one here so
we would say comma interior that will be
the default but but how do you now know
this is not the subtended version well
there's a rule inside of them what do
you mean by sup to the substandard
version you mean you mean how do you I
see what you're saying yeah the poly if
you're standing at a that polygon will
block out a a bunch of Thetas yeah and
that's not what we want we just saw the
part that's local to the breath
exactly exactly yes
I mean of course yeah
right but that thing could be part of
this more general you know subtended
angle angle the rule could mean yeah in
the case of subtended angle it could
mean I mean it's only gonna make a
difference if you have a regular
pentagon or something it doesn't make
any difference the two are the same so
for instance if you have a polyhedron
the two kinds of angles going on in it
you have the regular sort of planar
angle or 1d angles are called dihedral
angles those are the angles between the
faces yes but you also have at each
corner point you have you know a a solid
angle yes yes yes yes yes he draw angle
and solid angle of the two we are right
so how would we deal with okay so let's
take a look at a point of a polyhedron
okay so let's imagine we've got
subtended angle well so what you say I
would argue line is the dihedral angle I
mean they're planes and so you you could
say that it's the angle between the
normals for instance Hedra angle is is
given a hinge right in the polyhedron if
I'm not mistaken I should be line goes
to polygon polygon is to plain polygon
in 3d but what if it's or not what if
it's a hinge of a polyhedron doesn't
that have a meaning
well I'm sorry that's actually the wrong
thing it's a different angle that we
want there is an angle which is the
hinge angle between two faces faces mmm
yeah right which might almost be planar
angle of that since the angle between
two faces like isn't a pair of faces
determined by their edge that they share
sure but the angle between them is
determinate is the angle between the
normals to those two faces yes so okay
but then
you're saying there's a subtended angle
which is this for example the solid
angle at a point that's correct yes okay
what is the dihedral angle what's
definition of that which of these which
that's the first one it's the what you
call hinge angle okay okay so if you're
dealing with the polyhedron you
presumably have indices in the
polyhedron representing its its some but
the most natural arguments what this one
would be two phases also in a line and
the whole polyhedral yes okay fine well
but only so you know adjacent preferable
so how would you how would you do that
how would you specify that this fact
that the line goes to and then you have
these two faces the same house for the
the planar case to the case where you
have a point on the end a one dimension
up I say okay fine yeah and the polygon
the black is not even needed or similar
in the planar case what just should not
do the point of intersection specified
it is not needed you can deduce the to
face up and vice versa
it's polygons are assumed to have
surface normals defined by some right
hand rule or something is that correct
yeah if you have a polyhedron you have
there - you have interior and exterior
and end and so that's why you need a
whole object because then you can say
what's inside and what's outside well so
ok so what's correct here
so this one is correct right but in the
dihedral angle right it's really the
angle between one guy's interior normal
and the other guy's exterior angle like
this if they're nearly parallel you want
that angle to be PI not zero I don't
know that convention but yeah okay all
right but let's go back up here so do we
believe that fundamentally okay so this
case is a little bit funky because it's
not a subtended angle it's what we're
calling the planar angle which is some
kind of whereas the subtended angle
which is perfectly meaningful thing I
think that the rule in this case is a
little bit misleading in this case here
yeah what would you do two arguments but
then how do you deal with this thing
because that's that's then result well
how would you deal with this case then
the planar angle look the simplest case
of the planar angle look the whole point
is the high-school case of the planar
angle is this end the polygon one I mean
implicitly
is this this considers two lines right
one between a and B one between B and C
yeah yes you know it's just sort of you
know the bare-bones information that you
need are the actual three points right
and it doesn't duplicate the be done
right so what are you saying here
and also does it least miss the
classical notation
anga sign and then come three points
that's true one thing that one can do
dosa sort of special you know special
input forms yeah what's the general
input form usually we kind of build an
angle object right and then the rest are
constructor which are different input
form from polygon to you know cheap wine
to curve and ended you know don't
evaluate to an object which represent
have a canonical presentation for us
well what are you suggesting Charles
that we have three different functions
that all turn into an angle object um I
don't think we want that because we
don't actually want things that
transform too much because we're trying
to keep these geometric theorems in
terms of the things that you gave as
input earlier we definitely do not want
to go to it angular objects because we
want the Enkidu proposed in the measure
right that's kind of one of the issue
with that synthetic geometry in term of
there is a lot of language concept you
just need to add you don't you don't
have to evaluate actually Michael we
discuss about it it's when we try to
merge both is kind of get it isn't
really not right so we need to make that
distinction like now we have you know
perpendicular or sort you don't evaluate
or have no meaning you should probably
introduce more of those object for the
synthetic geometry and not expect that
the geometric side will actually
evaluate or try to remember
perpendicular
well this perpendicular a does it
evaluate to true if it knows if it has
explicit lines
I don't imprison since perpendicular is
just formatting in synthetic geometry
we're no longer using the perpendicular
symbol because we switch to geometric
assertion with a string argument
perpendicular okay okay fine okay so
again let's goes around us again all
right we've got this rather alighted
form yeah this in geometric scene I
would like to falsely light and not even
mention the point oh sure right it can
just be ABC I don't think that's
particular to the geometric scene
because point is a point set yeah what
the point primitive that you're using
there represents a point set not an
actual point like you can't take a point
and put it in the vertices of a line and
rigorously you can take just a war pair
of coordinate and declare to be a point
time but isn't this the fully decorated
form of what you're doing in the
geometric and the geometric same thing
no no the point I think represents a
region and we just want a confused by
that so you say well I've written a
point point point all over the place
here that's wrong but it either has to
be an explicit
point with an XY coordinate or it's an
ABC symbolic value that is declared in
the list of sort of point variables in
geometric scene is that right yeah
that's the way it is now okay well fair
enough I don't see a problem with that
okay so let's go back let's go around
again then so planar angle in the case
where those ABC are explicitly so let's
write out what it would be it will be
you know something like x1 y1 x2 y2 x3
y3 would evaluate correct yeah I think
so okay okay so now the case that we're
trying to deal with is you know we could
have a completely different thing called
polygon angle is that what you believe
is worthwhile either if we could find a
way to unify them into a small set of
symbols I think that would be nice but
we do need to be able to describe the
different concepts of angles somehow
clearly needs to be a different symbol
if we can I mean the planar angle really
is a polygon angle where the polygon the
triangle okay so
trust in claim
that's a good point
well that makes a suggestion then okay
with that idea in mind
okay I'm gonna make the claim
the obvious thing to do is that that's
equivalent of this
completely crazy
I'm sorry was it for them to what this
thing here the regular case right and
that this that then with that being seen
as a triangle its equivalent to saying
polygon of those things arrow to he
claims
Damali got the polygon case you don't
the polygon case is introduced precisely
because we don't want the proper angle
we want the interior and exterior okay
okay forget the word proper angle here
well that's what makes the two things
incomparable though in our first case
you're talking about proper
counterclockwise and clockwise in second
case you're talking about interior
exterior never you give this James the
string yeah yeah yeah the string is not
the problem here the issue is what the
first argument I mean we can we can have
I mean
okay it so happens that for the triangle
case this will agree right yes
you
okay one of the questions is that too
what will be a natural way to indicate
what I'm saying I mean so the
alternative here would be
the stay BC ro2
or you want if I'm not mistaken
well do you in fact want this
I mean because the 1d case is of no
interest we could allow booth you know
by - you mean index - right yeah that's
correct so I think it's synthetic
geometry we would prefer goes to be
rather than goes to - okay but then this
this case is a Pentagon right what's the
problem is it I would say a problem with
this so um or equivalently this or the
symbolic representation of that polygon
would be an equivalent form for that
sure I I kind of think this is the wrong
way around I think it should be - arrow
this thing will be amazing - but did you
modular the confucian list is obtained
that yes I agree what do you guys do
when you have repeated points repeated
variables in there in a polygon hmm
we you mean it's user input or very
intentional intentional right it so in
the inside of geometric scene it is
assumed that all polygons are simple so
if you repeat a point things don't work
so right so is the suggestion is that
interior angle is the default yes
and then right so well what if you don't
have a rule then it's not a polygon then
it's then it is the case of then it's
the non polygon case
so if you give five things there and
it's the non polygon case then it's an
error okay so precisely so you can avoid
the rule if and only if you have a list
of three things right but okay explain
to me okay so but in fact we're thinking
of switching these around so this is two
arrow B arrow right right which also
does better in terms of the subtended
thing I think well I did but the
subtended thing is a different thing why
are you saying for for this attended
angle function subtended angle function
I'm saying it's better because it's a
point arrow polygon which makes a lot
more sense to me
right in still a while if it's just
three points not having me oh yeah no
rule in the case of three points you
don't need a rule so
that there is a current now interior
angle we can certainly let allow people
to use the term interior angle but it's
rather degenerate in this case it would
be instead proper angle and so on
makes sense and even Baba angry can be
skipped and it is Papa angered by d4
yeah exactly
right well I mean isn't it that interior
angle is the default and proper angle is
just a synonym I mean I think so
interior angle of the triangle is it not
the case that interior angle of the
triangle is equivalent to prop rang
there they are synonyms that's why the
swords so maybe we just need proper
angle at all right Bolton I think for
people because I think it's a pick it
will be clearer to people well I don't
know you tell me I mean I think I think
the only difference would be the scene
geography saw interior angle would draw
the polygon we could just a proper angle
would would not draw the polygon
assuming you to list the point - not a
polygon head maybe okay if you so what
so if are reeling this list of points to
have a polygon head - correct
yes so if they did a polygon polygon ABC
kind of a proper angle but that would be
we'd allow that honestly I don't see the
point in having proper angle well okay
fine I mean the only possible reason I
think is for three naked points to you
know allow it to draw you know it's just
sort of two line segments and a little
thing little curved as opposed to a
triangle but maybe it can do that anyway
I don't know if polygon without a rule
should work yeah I'm not sure it should
work I don't think it should work
so we would allow lists EVC or we would
allow rule unlisted ABC or rule and
polygon yep an interior angle I think is
gonna be reasonably clear to people but
that's the default okay okay fine I I
can't speak to that because I don't know
high school geometry
I mean how its taught and so on okay so
then the notion is the right term
clockwise angle so did addressing the
other case right the case of okay so the
the thing angle indicator is the visual
that is a disembodied visual
independent of the scene drawer probably
not something we implement immediately
um in the scene drawer by the way and
this is something sound or our live
stream has mentioned when you have two
equal lines do we get the thing that the
little chick chick check check things
that indicate that they're equal those
things are very arbitrary because you
don't have one of them on a diagram
right well I mean you could so currently
we do not you could have I mean provide
stairs in high school geometry you would
you if you had two sets of lines of
equal length one would have a single
teen are gonna come to live to eat and
then if they're parallel you have you
have arrows too that's that's not
currently implemented but it's planned
for at least some version okay it's a
little tricky to to implement because
also I mean you could draw on all the
plot markers that we've developed there
to you I mean you probably should use
those traditional ones too but yeah but
use whatever weird icons you want to say
this is the same as this yeah it's the
main thing you want to do right identify
two things okay
so or quality of them the length in this
case weren't by the way this generalizes
reasonably nicely to the 3d dihedral
angle case and so on what we've
discussed here I believe
okay and subtended angle is then a
separate thing which we're not yet
implementing right oh I'm sorry we're
back to clockwise and anti-clockwise
angles is that I'm my brain is fuzzing
out here is that that's always the
meaningful way to do it right to say
[ __ ] wise given ABC there's an ordering
ABC right right so assuming you you take
a B as your as your first guy and BC is
your second guy then yes five plays and
hundred pathways are well-defined from
there okay
sound reasonable to people then but
that's what we and others the right
names I guess they are I can't see any
other other way to name them we could
support anti-clockwise in addition to
counterclockwise is fine okay nothing
else here do you is that me the network
the
what does conjugate exterior so for the
exterior angle so the the exterior angle
of a polygon is this normally the
supplementary exterior polygon angle
where you extend the the incident edge
of the polygon the conjugate exterior
polygon angle is the the angle on the
opposite side of the interior angle that
adds up to 360 degrees it's almost
impossible to understand without seeing
a picture well there's a picture of this
girl down oh also exploit explore that
it's not a real word it is apparently we
mean by a parent okay so let's send it
to the outside of duty spelling so the
usual sense of exterior angle is like
the angle in the top picture with the
dotted line okay you won and didn't take
the piece left right it really gives a
you know two angle objects but they have
the same measure oh okay
as opposed to the normal one okay so
you're saying that when we've set
interior angle an exterior angle that
actually isn't what we mean by exterior
angle I mean this is what I would have
assumed exterior angle meant that's what
I did too I would assume the other right
it's about 50/50 according to the
Wikipedia article oh god what a mess I
know right okay so what are we gonna
call these things because we're never
gonna remember which is which
well so the so that the top line I mean
supplementary is pretty well is he's
pretty widely so this is kind of this is
the supplementary exterior angle and as
opposed to supplementary angle right
supplementary angles add up to 180
degrees although they don't necessarily
have to be adjacent
so this up we'd say the supplementary
exterior angle why do you need the wood
exterior though I mean isn't
supplementary so we've got three points
ABC and we're trying to describe what is
the which I'm described this angle here
correct and the other one oh boy one is
the conjugate of the interior angle okay
so one of them is which is and the other
one is essentially the turn yes right
which is a supplement of the interior
angle right turn to go from one edge to
the next aka supplement of the interior
angle
boy you know nothing is easy here okay
alright so at least interior angle seems
to be well-defined yes
while there are two different conditions
on exterior people the supplementary
version is more common and in high
school days and that supplementary is
also a common case in computational
geometry okay well so we have to call it
supplementary exterior angle I think it
I think it deserves to just be called
exterior angle the exterior as I do mind
if I would think it was this one here
what would you call this one the
complementary great so now I want to go
from entry one called complementary
complementary is 90 - yeah
time to get odd you can do it yeah I
think exterior angle should go with the
one that's most likely to be understood
by the high school audience I don't
agree I don't agree because the interior
angle I would think this was the
exterior angle if I just heard it
episode you see that's not what the
majority of to be seen but is there an
is there a more less ambiguous name for
us ambiguous than conjugate no no no
okay so talking about this one conjugate
but what about this one here what's the
least ambiguous name for that one
they're supplementary exterior angle
then that's what we should call it is
there a is there a name for this one
that would be I mean could we call this
1 conjugate exterior angle where is that
obscure that's okay I think both are
obscure but it's less obscure than
exponent exterior angle yeah which we
don't even know as a spell check would
but at least this one has methods but
the other one there's no lipids well I
mean could this be called okay another
possible name complete exterior angle is
that crazy I I would like exterior angle
and complete exterior angle it's just a
question of are we willing to confuse
the high school students by having the
word supplementary that yeah okay I
can't I don't know because I don't know
high school geometry I think that that's
suggestion exterior angle and complete
exterior angle that sounds you think
that's reasonable I think that's pretty
damn race no yeah okay okay all right
are we done here we got some questions
from our live stream from chillin cat
first states positive angles are usually
counterclockwise that's true when you're
in the
I think that's not relevant to what we
are I think for alternate names for a
counterclockwise and clockwise you could
also sometimes be positively oriented
and negatively oriented right but the
angle the point is not the value of the
angle the problem is how you get from
the sequence of points ABC to an angle
right um and I think that clockwise and
counter clockwise seem less obscure um
right and chillin cat also us about what
about angles in non-orientable objects
we discussed that earlier and hopefully
those I don't know whether these that
shit's a good question whether these
names work where did you have your
picture for that guy do these names make
any sense for that guy yeah yeah they
are well-defined I think you you look at
what gets tell her then so the exterior
angles of 30 or the interior angles of
36 degrees and the exterior angles are
144 the complete exterior angle would be
River 360 minus 36 is right the young
whatever um okay fair enough
all right do we think we're done here
I'm happy you know I think there's a
pretty good solution nothing new yep I
will send a notebook who am i sending
this to or my city to me eyes forwarded
content to teachers also desolate okay
all right
okay thank you all on the live stream
thank you locally talk you'll soon
you